[Music]
did you pass I'll choose you say my name
so my powers will become yours
[Music]
I'd like to purchase some of your finest
beer please Sam Claire yes if you have a
location like on a cliff like a castle
ass type thing you're looking some water
get some water splashing on rocks and
something we will take that experience
it in IMAX you've run from foster homes
in six counties I can take care of
myself when you're 18 give these people
a chance because that's what they're
giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real Game of Thrones around here dude
just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're just able
to foster kid you've got it all if you
could have one superpower what would you
think everybody chooses flight you don't
like so they can fly away from this
conversation no cuz heroes fly well you
need your fake family to stand up for
you hey man sorry about that
Billy Batson
I choose you
Mussa champion
hello
say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your name
sir wait for you okay
Shazam
Billy you're the only person I know that
knows anything about this Cape Crusader
stuff tonight yeah that's crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing okay why are you talking your
post cards your phone charge beach like
a bad guy right
you have full immunity Wolfram you're
dead sorry about your window but now a
welcome for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]